[Musique]
dimanche soir peu avant minuit près du
pont neuf à paris un véhicule lancé à
toute allure aurait forcé un contrôle de
police l'enquète sur la mort de deux
hommes sur le pont-neuf dimanche après
un refus d'obtempérer un drap dans l'un
des quartiers les plus touristiques de
paris un agent va alors ouvrir le feu
sur la voiture tirant à dix reprises et
tuant le conducteur et son passager six
impacts seront relevés sur le pare brise
si cet agent de 24 ans invoque le
principe de légitime défense le parquet
paris a pourtant ouvert une enquête pour
homicide volontaire et pour violences
volontaires par personne dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
le syndicat est catégorique il ne
laisseront pas leur collègue être la
victime d'un système judiciaire selon
eux défaillant des rassemblements sont
prévues lundi pour protester contre une
telle injustice alors légitime défense
deux hommes tués après un refus
d'obtempérer comprenez vous que le
policier soit mise en examen alors alors
il ya plusieurs primes qui sont posées
évidemment la riposte la légitime
défense en revanche la mise en examen
pour meurtre ça promet si volontaire
c'est est-ce que c'est pas un peu le
maximum gilles de ce que le parquet
pouvait requérir le parquet n'avait pas
requis ce sont les juges qui ont été
au-delà en estimant qu'il y avait
volonté de tuer ça va ça va très loin
parce que ils ont estimé que la légitime
défense n'était pas retenu pour le
moment ça peut évoluer au fil de
l'instruction d'ailleurs il n'a pas été
incarcéré il a été remis en liberté sous
contrôle judiciaire donc ça a évolué et
il est désarmé il est désarmé il initie
draconien au médecin dit j'ai pas
incarcéré mais néanmoins c'est
extrêmement rarissime vous l'avez dit
homicide volontaire c'est à dire que il
estime qu'il a tiré alors qu'il aurait
pu éviter de tuer des gens ils n'étaient
pas en ait pas de danger absolu a juste
vous rappeler il ya un lien une gendarme
et à quelques temps qui s'est fait
écraser donc l'avait pas usage de son
arme et là maintenant la question et si
on ne fait pas usage de son arme qu'on
se fait renverser alors à savoir quelle
est la juste valeur l'épicier défense
doit être proportionnée à l'attaqué le
rêve très bien pu tiré dans les pneus
d'autant qu'il avait un fusil d'alors il
était à dix reprises info il faut dire
qu il dira 5 sur cette affaire car les
deux policiers ya deux policiers qui
sont venus d'abord avec une lampe torche
pour les contrôler au moment où ils ont
été contrôlés ils ont d leur voiture la
policière a tenu volant à couvrir un peu
allez tomber ils ont foncé sur les
hommes politiques enfin c'est les autres
policiers en face dont ce policier qui a
tiré alors je dis pas qu'il acquit la
raison ou pas mais il faut ça quand ils
se font ces dessus le réflexe de se dire
je vais viser les pneus je suis d'accord
mais y'a un moment il ya quelqu'un qui
va pour écraser 3,3 flic ou alors c'est
un sujet en or il est très fort ça va
très vite dans ce jeu non je dis pas qui
avait raison donc c'est normal qu'ils
sont remises à des hommes façon faut
enquêter c'est normal on retrouve faut
savoir si c'est vrai ou pas ce sont les
enquêtes quand il ya eu usage de l'armé
n plus compliqué juste il ya des
syndicats qui sont exposés qui ont
expliqué qu'en fait comme il avait
larmes en bandoulière synthé l'âme qui
était accessible de tir et quasiment ses
il ya une fraction de seconde dont
pierre sescosse côté syndical ultra en
colère très remontée la da costa caisse
coup ça pose la question quand même sur
la formation est ce que nos policiers
sont suffisamment bien formés se
rappelle donc que ce jeune homme le
policier avait 24 ans c'est extrêmement
cher savoir que la criminalité elle a
beaucoup évolué mais alors est ce qu'il
faudrait pas intéresser un peu plus les
choses à apprendre oui mais je me peux
faire mais je veux dire former quand une
voiture force sur un policier est
toujours attention je dis pas qu'ils
avaient raison pas je me pose la
question si on fonce sur quelqu'un est
ce que ces informations de dire pour
atteindre tu va analyser la vitesse qui
va être là dans des maîtres donc tu as
dit soit il ya un moment il faut foncer
dessus je dis pas que les autres pays
ont raison il ya d'autres pays tapant
des fourrages dire déjà si un contrôle
on redémarre pas on s'arrête et si on a
quelque chose à se reprocher si nous
avait on démarre pas en face pas sur les
flics ils ont là lorsqu'il ya une
transaction de drogue parce que le père
fasse da par l'exclusion oui j'étais
derrière était apparemment le client il
était donc évident il n'avait pas
intérêt à s'arrêter voilà oui mais quand
même le patio lisez bien ce qu'on nous
parle de la liste les invités sont les
visant à mettre fin aux pattes parce que
peut-être qu'ils voulaient les tuer
aussi offert les écrasera on ne sait pas
encore qui est peut-être
disproportionnée ses larmes que posséder
ce policier
de mayotte
depuis le bataclan la police est
effectivement tu te retrouves face à des
gars qui ont des causes mais si le
soleil dans ceux évidemment que du coup
il a tiré des balles et il a tué deux
personnes c'est ainsi sage et bien sûr
que c'était pour ça ont la trouille qui
contrôlent l'île de la cité au coeur de
paris qui est un site extrêmement
sensible arrivé qu'après justice voilà à
l'exercice la préfecture de police et
cetera notre dame voilà notre dame ce
qui étonne c'est que ce policier de 24
ans d'ailleurs héros puisqu'il avait
sauvé
vous me tendait une perche je la saisis
et voici un extrait il y à un mois cet
homme-là était un héros il a 24 on l'a
dit il et réunionnais il est dans la
police depuis 10e 18 mois il est
toujours stagiaires ils avaient
l'habilitation g36 et il y à un mois ce
jeune fonctionnaire de police a plongé
dans la seine pour aller chercher une
femme désespérée qui avait tenté de se
suicider ça ne change rien à la gravité
des faits qui lui sont c'est aujourd'hui
c'est exagère mais c'est un policier
exemplaire alors police exemplaires on
l'a dit les syndicats sont vent debout
et protègent leurs collègues et juste
avant qu'on voit le justement le coup de
gueule du syndicat l'interpellation dans
les délits de fuite est compliquée par
la police parce que parfois dans 30 %
des cas paraît-il sont des gens qui font
simplement en serait ce parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'assurance pas ce cas pas de
métier je vous dis je vous dis si les
chiffres et qu' ils savent pas s'ils ont
affaire à des vrais truands ou à des
gens en panique donc d'où la riposte qui
parfois est un petit peu on va dire
exagéré c'est absolument et là les juges
ont estimé jean pascal qu' il n'y avait
pas de danger grave et imminent pour ça
qu'il a été mis en examen pour homicide
volontaire voilà est évident que
syndicats et elles sont très en colère
regardez
ne peux pas accepter qu'on aujourd'hui
qu'on dise que notre collègue a voulu
tuer volontairement cet individu qui je
rappelle et à minuit trois individus
dans une voiture à côté d'un site
sensible la préfecture de police
le palais de justice nous avons savons
et nous avons su par la suite que ces
individus sont très connus des services
de police un moment donné il faut
arrêter on est tombé sur la tête de
qualifier notre collègue de meurtriers
oui encore noté que la mise en examen
elle est normal parce qu'effectivement
il ya homicides dont bienvenus donc
tu peux m'empêcher dans son sens c'est à
dire que ya des signes à deux décès ces
drames c'est grave donc c'est normal
mais par contre le motif de la mise en
examen et qu'on reproche à cet homme de
cette levée pour tuer quelqu'un je pense
qu'il s'est pas levé le matin en disant
tiens je vais lecture rapporte qu'il a
fait non paniqué parce que manque de
formation parce que plein de choses mais
qu'à un moment donné on peut pas
toujours s'en prendre à la police parce
que la police il faut quand même soulevé
qui font un travail formidable qui
sommes des milliers ou des deux de vie
tous les jours et qu'on est quand même à
les appeler à chaque fois qu'on a besoin
il se met en danger et maintenant basse
et même sur deux sièges mais deux
policiers le jeune tu vois ce que tu
appelles kelly là il a gâché sa vie mais
pauvre alors là on va attendre
il a peut-être
sauvé la vie à trois policiers et que
psychologiquement il va être il va être
ravie de ça c'est pas écouter écouter
l'avocat du policier qui
je comprends la bonne intention des
policiers qui veulent soutenir le jeune
fonctionnaire qui est mise en examen
aujourd'hui mais je considère que c'est
pas un petit peu dangereux parce que ce
se dresser contre l'institution
judiciaire alors que les juges
d'instruction quand ils ont retenu leur
qualification ils n'ont fait
qu'appliquer la jurisprudence constante
quand on tire avec une arme à feu sur
quelqu'un c'est qu'on veut le tuer c'est
ce que dit la jurisprudence donc leur
démarche si elle n'est pas pertinente
elle est en tout cas légitime elle est
en tout cas conforme à la jurisprudence
enfin qu'il me souviens de ces frais
pour pouvoir ensuite éventuellement la
rabaisser au fur et à mesure des
explications c'est ça ce que vous nous
dites m mais absolument comme c'est le
cas depuis c'est le cas très souvent et
ce matin la famille
à réagir regardez
lors de mon reportage vierge interrogé
des habitants de ce petit quartier
populaire du 20e arrondissement de paris
le quartier des amandiers et un homme
d'une trentaine d'années s'adresse à moi
tout à fait par hasard et lâche cette
phrase ce sont mes petits frères qui
sont morts j'apprends qui est l'aîné
d'une grande fratrie il raconte qu'avec
leur mère ils sont en deuil anéantie on
ne comprend pas ce qui a pu se passer
comment un policier a pu tirer au fusil
d'assaut sur mes frères il explique
qu'il attend des réponses les
réponses qu'est ce qu'on peut avoir
comme réponse objectivement longue
instruction pour le moment si ça reste
en l'état le policier risque les assises
j'ai effectivement bah oui mais
effectivement l'instruction pourrait
montrer avec les expertises balistiques
qu'il n'y avait pas intention d'appeler
d'une cro tenir éventuellement légitimes
des livres je voue une question imaginer
le policier ne tire pas la voiture
écrase trois policiers c'est ça le truc
et ça me gêne faveur des lycées réponse
à votre question ces questions là le
vrai que sa fille était bien sûr la
vraie question mais le problème pour
embarquer comme ça on peut voir à
travers les yeux du policier qu'est ce
qu'il a pu ressentir qu'est-ce que re
visionner et revisionner en fait à
chaque fois la vidéo et se dire oui
peut-être qu'à ce moment-là rock ska
nation ils sont pas équipés de caméras
mais non pas là où ils se trouvent enfin
si vous n'avez qu'à venir à bout une
moto qui fonde sur vous lors effectue
donc c'est vraiment c'est un métier
tellement dit si c'est une vocation
tellement difficile et je pense pas
qu'il ya un problème de formation parce
que les formations c'est quand même très
strictes et est très exigeant mais en
revanche ça ne reste que des hommes et
tous les matins ils partent ils
embrassent leur chéri et leurs enfants
et ils savent pas s'ils vont rentrer le
soir et je pense que il ya vraiment
quelque chose à gérer entre la justice
et entre la police parce que la police
aujourd'hui se sent un peu démunis il
n'y a pas assez de moyens et puis
généralement quand il arrête quelqu'un
eh ben la justice est toujours un peu
inférieur et donc les gens ressortent
donc aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faudrait
simplement réunifiée vraiment la justice
et les policiers et qu'on pense à
améliorer la loi par rapport à cette la
dépense pour proportionnelle sur la
légitime défense la loi elle est
extrêmement cadré benjamin on a tous les
éléments ça existe depuis longtemps
voilà vous l'avez derrière vous est ce
qu'il ya une menace réelle la
proportionnalité maxime l'a dit et il
faut noter qu'il y avait un témoin
direct de la scène un chauffeur de taxi
qui est allé dans le sens des policiers
d'accord c'était moins directe malgré ça
râle grayssas les juges ont mis en
examen pour homicide volontaire